[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody
hello chess fans we're back here closing
out 2019 at the world-renowned st. Louis
Chess Club for a very special and crazy
wacky edition of well the first ever GM
showdown hello my name is Ben Simon and
I'm joined alongside Grandmaster Josh
Reed al has no idea what he's doing here
Josh welcome to the show sure yeah well
let's tell you what we're doing here
today a few months ago we debuted Mike
comers deranged new time control known
as intense chess you remember the old
UFC eight people go in one comes out
well that's what this was it was an
eight-person single-elimination knockout
game in one minute with a 10 second
delay and that's what we're doing here
tonight but the field is a little bit
stronger and by a little bit I mean a
lot Josh but meanwhile they have to play
Mike comers deranged time control while
looking at Mike comer with his crazy
mohawk the whole time and that to me is
actually the greatest challenge of this
format that not only do you have to play
this wacky time control you also have to
see Mike comer in his suit and with this
wacky mohawk the whole time it's a
blonde Mohawk and they might as well be
amateur players well Anna this is gonna
be one heck of event and if you haven't
seen Mike comer with his blonde Mohawk
get ready you're about to because he's
the tournament director for this match
now let's get to the players in this
match there's only two it's all for
pride okay so technically this is an
exhibition but it's all for pride two
veterans of the st. Louis chess club to
slough students st. Louis University
separated by several years in age and
experience this is going to be a lot of
fun first of all we have Grand Master
Alex it popped off who should get Top
Billing in my opinion in this match he
doesn't he is getting a b-side he's
representing Turkey apparently but he's
also he's represented two other
countries of course he was born in love
you Ukraine he played for Ukraine up
until 2009 evolved
the early leave one of the people
pronounce it differently Oh
my source says the view anyway love you
yeah something like that
what on earth he played for Spain until
2012 and then he was working closely
with the head of the National Federation
of Turkey he said okay well let's play
for Turkey starting in 2012 Alex he
popped off is the higher seed in this
event with a 26:31 classical theater
ating a 2587 universal rating anna 2584
feat a rapid and that's what today is
rapid so we're gonna be looking at the
feed a rapid rapid is the craziest rapid
you've ever heard of wasn't done let's
get to our well that's what happens when
you've been 10 minutes I want to play
another guy my gosh let's get to our a
side JJ Ali Miranda his name is Jamil
John Ali Mehran day because the season
his name his full name are pronounced
like Jays in Turkish so he's Grandmaster
JJ Ali morandi that's what he goes by 21
years old he's an undergrad at SLU 2553
feat a rapid now we're gonna be talking
about a lot of these a lot of the
different facets of these players I've
been talking to them all day today in
preparation for this match but we're
gonna have four games we're gonna have
four games game in one minute with a
10-second delay so you're gonna have
time it's a rapid time control okay by
the rulebook but these are unrated games
there's exhibition only so we are just
about time to go to the battleground I
know that the players must be getting
antsy over there across the hall Josh
what would you be thinking right now if
you were about to engage in this heck of
a matchup I mean a man what kind of time
grateful is this when they walked in
yeah I think I think that they're like I
can tell you these guys are you know
they're college students and they really
are college students they're studying
there and their focus on studies they
just finished midterms they both want to
relax chill but instead they have to
play this match yeah which means that
they're but at the same time they're
competitive guys they're gonna want to
try to win so I think we'll see some
entertaining games I don't know how
clean
lb and but for us it doesn't matter they
make mistakes it's fine if they don't
that's also why it should be a lot of
fun and we've got our friend Nick risk
go in the other room he'll be taking
down the move so we can maybe do some
analysis along the way but as I a wait
word when when Mike Hummer is got the
players seated and ready in the other
room we'll be ready to go but oh wait I
hear we are ready so let's go to our
tournament director the most exciting
man in all of chess Michael J comer one
and all to this intense chess
spectacular
all right welcome one at all to this
intense just spectacular
we are so honored to be greeted by JJ a
lemur and a three-time world champion of
the protest League Archbishop's of st.
Louis his challenger today 2012 world
junior champion Alexander a pot of
intense chess it's a game like no other
created by myself and club manager
Jonathan Krantz
you get one minute base time and then a
10-second delay so pace yourself it's
gonna be intense
you may begin and we are off to the
races the players have been briefed and
introduced in only the championship
fashion that might cover and can give
and well we have hot dogs white pieces
what's going on here Josh so he spent
like ten second he spent all his ten
seconds but note how the like normally
in a blitz game if you spend ten seconds
on move to you're kind of an idiot but
he's not because he didn't lose any time
as you'll notice but he put off he I put
on for whatever if I decide to say of
course yeah yeah so he likes to play
kind of out there outlandish stuff when
he played against me he also played some
pretty crazy stuff and that was in a
classical game so there's no doubt but
before is relatively normal before
Bishop b2 h4 is a little weird but hey
you know but okay so far it doesn't look
like anything crazy has happened
probably he'll try to play with like c4
at some point gave up his night oh my
goodness there he goes now normally when
people play the moves I suggest nothing
goes well for them but we'll see if this
is an exception so I don't know probably
there should be 293 83 something like
this yeah so you have to watch out for
94 cuz the pin but probably Queen c2
doesn't do that much so yeah I don't
know this h4 h5 inclusion I'm kind of
tempted to say I like it for black
because black stone with the fianchetto
bishop
so the King looks a little bit safer to
my eyes but at the same time it's still
you
know anyone's game because it's hard for
white to ever Castle queenside with all
those pawns up now these two players
they go way back I mean it's at least
twenty eleven and I was talking to them
about the histories with each other
earlier today and it started in 2012
whenever it paid off joined the Turkish
national team and they were on that
together they're very good friends this
is what JJ says and JJ says that he
hopes that their friendship can survive
this match he doesn't want any rules
violations or disputes to come between
them so this is definitely a friendly
match unrated there's there's nothing on
the line here except the pride of saying
I beat you in intense chess yeah and
there's a lot of pride can't say I'm too
crazy about what JJ just did I like
putting the fishermen have five nice and
solid
keep Queen out of situ here because of
the trades that have happened now all of
a sudden g4 is always in the air which
at least to my mind slightly annoying
probably black still doin just fine but
I would have played it slightly
differently and you'll notice both guys
have lost only a few seconds although
both of is now ticking down and keep in
mind you don't get that time back so if
he goes down to 30 seconds that's half
the time of your game lost so if I were
him I would make a decision relatively
fast but he's trying to determine
whether he can take on d5 take on d7
moves like g4 don't quite work cuz you
trade on e5 and then take but but it's
kind of a weird situation like he has to
decide what to do so he's just castling
so now taking on e5 is harder cuz after
the recapture d5 becomes weak and again
he really wants to play g4 you can see
it's on his mind he's an aggressive
minded player but the problem is when
you castle in your palms on before your
opponent can play a five however I don't
know how easy it is for JJ to actually
open up the game here I guess we'll find
out but definitely we have an exciting
position on our hands
he follows down to 28 seconds and JJ
still is over 50 so that's the one issue
that you thought of might have here the
pacing of these games is so off the wall
bonkers because yeah your brains like I
have one minute but that 10 seconds
really does make a big difference here
this doesn't really play like a blitz
game
I would say it's between gluts and rapid
first of all I would say it's a weird
time control however no yeah but at the
same time yeah it's between books and
rappers but I would say that like in
rapid getting a position that's easy to
play is sometimes more important than
getting in a good position so if you're
slightly worse but you know exactly what
you're doing and your opponent's play is
less clear that can be a big advantage
because you can't take long things so if
you have a tough decision to make it can
be very tricky I'd like to say thanks
for joining us in the chat everyone I
know Patrick Daly is in helping us out
with the rules he knows all the rules of
this he's listening so thanks for
letting everybody know what's up Patrick
and joining us as always he's a fan of
your commentary he loves what you have
to say about about this format a fan of
my commentary he needs to stick around
there are not so many people his
description so I'm happy he's that I'm
happy Patrick's joining us here so yeah
I'm not exactly sure what's going on now
it's a weird position and now I can't
see it what about what do you make this
body language here the body language he
pop-ups kind of amused he's probably
like I'm playing some real garbage but
at least it's fun and JJ is more intense
but he's also amused and he was very
surprised but 94 and he shouldn't be
really good it seems like a pretty
normal idea but he is also probably
skeptical maybe 94 can come in I don't
know if I would have allowed 94
personally I think that if JJ kind of
moved his queen out brought his rook to
see aid I don't know I don't trust
White's King meanwhile it takes quite a
few moves to get at blacks so he put
those sac the exchange which I thought
he might so he's down the exchange but
he has the juicy d6 square I am not so
convinced this full compensation but
again objective value of the position
doesn't always matter it matters how you
can play it fast
and again if that bishop lands on d6 the
White King comes up the board the black
Kings out of play on g8 this could be a
practically difficult situation and as
you can see JJ is thinking he's his time
is running because he's not sure what
decision to make do I take that 9 Melo
bishop to land on d6 that's what just
happened so I think that this is
actually a little bit of an annoying
situation for him because it's just not
so easy to deal with that Bishop the
King comes to c3 the rook goes to b1 to
b4 and you're seeing this happen now
again like what do you do is black he
can't play King f88
so if I were him I would have actually
tried to left the rook on d8 and maybe
try to move the F Khan so either f6
around five so I can get my King into
the game because right now his King is
completely out of the game the advantage
he has is that it's not so easy for
white to actually take anything yeah
he's going for f6 or a five now so his
King can come in I would imagine
okay seven covering the seventh rank
makes a lot of sense
and yeah it's it's kind of a question of
whether white can accomplish anything
significant here or whether JJ is just
gonna be able to hold this position yeah
and f6 is kind of it's a little
double-edged also because you kind of
free wipe spawns the pawns can start
rolling a little bit but it's not clear
they're going anywhere too special so I
would imagine some move like rook
teafork here he decides to take the pawn
off the board first
so maybe e4 he'll try I don't know about
the bishop check cuz now King up five is
a real possibility and I don't think he
should have allowed that he's gonna be a
little mad at himself for doing that I
would have played you floor first yeah
so the King is an active King yeah it's
coming to g4 it's coming to maybe it's
me for and I don't think that he meant
to allow that in general active kings
and their name are annoying but at the
same time the position still unclear
because the pawn on e6 is still a slight
weakness I might even consider something
silly looking like rook e8 give up c4
and then activate my king but at the
same time ah so he's not even letting
him do it he's gonna play four check but
again still a very unclear position g6
is weak b6 is weak and that C pawn is
pretty well blockaded he'd love to play
rook d7 to d3 but it's hard to get time
for that maybe you can even try it now
yeah rook d7 might actually be an
interesting option but you even have to
watch out for rook c6 sometimes ah there
he goes so yeah and the problem is if
you try Bishop d6 check i play king d5
your two pieces that are attacked so i
checks on d4 so now he's kind of
wondering where to put the King so now
he has to watch out rook takes d4 and c3
could be quite nasty
he tries to take something and he
realizes that's why it goes back so he
might try to grab b6 at some point but
then JJ can attack the bishop and try to
take the D pawn but I'd say that JJ has
kind of gotten the position under
control the Brooks kind of passive is
not the nice active King on g2 and I bet
you we put off wishing he played before
earlier so yeah he's trying to be active
so if you take on d4 immediately King
takes c3 you can play rook back to E 1
and C 1 but if he ever tries to take a
pawn rook takes d4 might be extremely
strong he doesn't immediately so maybe
it still works but I'm not sure I'm
gonna run yeah it works because of
course the Kings on g2 right so he's
gonna play C 3 C 2 and then just start
taking pawns so he popped ons probably
losing because rook c6 are not in time I
take and then play C 2 C 1 and I prevent
you from cleaning yeah you're just
winning probably the rook also very
conveniently cuts the King off so I
can't go after b6 also quite important
so he's gonna try to play a 5 on them
probably but I have my doubts that this
will work
ah King f3 Buttrick seeds are you
checking yeah all right and there's the
handshake JJ and lemur on D strikes
first and you know as far as okay we
were hearing hearing some some talking
there from the players that's
interesting I like that board side
microphone I'm not gonna say it was me
to put it up but you know whoever did
was was pretty awesome at doing and let
me guess it was you been silent anyway
so this is a best-of poor match if
you're just joining us welcome what took
you so long
first a two and a half wins but all four
games will be played that's an important
note we left out earlier all four games
will be played and some of you have been
brought here I got to clear the air they
on the YouTube channel it says that
there's armwrestling if the match is
tied well that was originally the idea
it seems that there was some controversy
in one of the players not being notified
that that was going to be the playoff
procedure so and why would you tell
someone that they're going to
it doesn't seem like an important yeah
need-to-know terms and conditions' arm
wrestle many times to decide tie breaks
at tournaments I don't know what the
problem could possibly be but apparently
it didn't end up working out no the
funny thing is I talked to Jay Jay today
and I said Jay Jay we're gonna have arm
wrestling for the playoff how do you
feel about that and that's that's time
to talk about the event with in the
journalists role I'm fine and he said
well I just just learned that this
morning we'll talk about that in just a
moment here because Mike comer has our
winner
Jay Jay a Lima Ron day for an interview
all right all right I'm here with the
winner of Game one Jay Jay a Lima Ron
day so was that your first ever intense
chess victory yeah it actually was it's
my first time officially playing it
although I didn't get some training
today
before the event actually happened yeah
it's a very tricky time control I don't
know I still ended up with 15 seconds
but the time just starts flying at some
point right yeah when uh Alexander
decided to castlelong well you were a
bit surprised by that he thought for
like half his time just thinking about
that move but do you think it was good
or you think what were your thoughts
about it I think it was a very
double-edged decision I think it was
interesting at least
I shouldn't have allowed his 94 idea and
sacrificing the exchange I feel like the
ending was a little better for him but
he blundered me taking on d4 so overall
the game was interesting but yeah the
long causal decision slightly surprised
me I thought I had a good initiative but
didn't make it work the game resulted in
an end game all right well you win our
game won you got the white pieces in
game 2 things are looking up for you now
back to the studio thank you Mike you
seemed esteemed my comer as always with
the winner of the our first game JJ's
got to be feeling really good you know
how I always wondered the dynamics of
that look they're good friends they
train with each other they're on the
same page on the same national team on
the same cold collegiate team if I can
talk but
of course a Lima Ronde is is by rating
my strength the weaker player right he's
the b-side so striking first blood in
this crazy time control it's gotta mean
something Josh what do you think I think
it's a good thing I mean honestly I
wouldn't put too much on their ratings
first of all we're playing Mike comer is
absurd time control that already makes
it weird I know that Alex hasn't touched
chest for several months like not much
anyway maybe an occasional class he's
not studied JJ they've been focused on
other things so it's really about who's
tactically more alert honestly like
who's kind of ready and who kind of
adapts a little bit better so I wouldn't
put too much into the ratings I would
say that it would have been a toss-up
but getting a win with black in the
first game getting or at least the
confidence because you know that if you
win with white then your opponent has a
huge mountain to climb
so absolutely so it's really a big thing
to get a win for black in the first game
so well and like I was saying before
that interview the the people wondering
about the armwrestling reference I
talked to JJ earlier today and I said JJ
you guys are gonna be arm wrestling for
the playoff and how do you feel about
that and he says I don't think it's fair
I don't like it and I didn't know about
it until this morning well my favorite
part was where he was like he said that
Alex was you know is has been arm
wrestling for years as an implying he's
been like touring the country arm
wrestling a professional complement to
the smokiest of bombers is true which
could be true but I doubt right most
likely it's just he law I think he lost
to Matt at one time because they've
roomed several times and guys have
nothing better to do so the arm wrestle
to dispute like you know who gets the
extra Claire or something and then they
do it and he lost so I think he that
lost was in his memory
so he's really hoping to win it by
Chesson this is a pretty good start well
we're gonna see whether you can win it
by chess here is game number two the
players are all set up the colors have
changed let's go back to the
battleground
yeah win it by chess is the name of my
new book all right it's game 2
Alexander you may begin all right here
we go oh what a treat I didn't know
comer was gonna talk again right there
yeah uh II pontiff's continuing the
tradition he's feeling shadowing his
bishop for no reason so this game it
looks more normal more recognizable to
someone like me Josh really yes Oh H for
what do you know so why is this more
recognizable to you Vincent moon because
the center pawn moved forward not the
b-pawn and the bishop is on f4 so he's
letting him play E for cuz no one likes
the center anyway makes sense to me why
take the center when you can just be in
shadow your bishops is there ever an
instance where these 284 come on guys
there okay so what's wrong with you so
they're playing wacky stuff in the way
of time control is there are they hiding
their best from each other or from the
general hiding their best from
themselves that's what they're doing
then hiding their best from themselves
so we have a pot top there with d6 of
course a pot off on the so JJ decides oh
he puts a pawn in the second part in the
center look at this odd of Hippo we got
the hippo going oh yeah the hippo is
that a real name yeah what this is
called believe it or not was played
against me in a US Championship okay by
none other than Timur Griffith Oh
2013-2014 oh and I will say that the
opening didn't turn out well for him but
he made a comeback but and then I was
luckily able to win so I didn't have to
hide my head in shame but in general the
hippo is tricky because you have to know
kind of where to put your pieces the
problem for black is that you don't have
too many improving moves so if you're
white and the way I tried to play it
against grave I played nice and patient
which doesn't seem like that's what Jo
is doing but I played nice and patient
and eventually he ran out of improving
moves because it's really hard to make a
break for black if all your pieces are
kind of stuck on the first two rings
yeah and that's quite well illustrated
right there yeah so maybe he'll try a 9h
to g4 trying to play f4 looks pretty
reasonable
Patrick Daly says Josh sounds so
exasperated I think a part of him died
inside when JJ played a fool there's
gonna be nothing left
gonna be nothing laughs I'm gonna be an
empty shell I might as well bury me in
the backyard so met h2 to g4 he's taking
my advice once again oh my goodness he
played out five and notice how he kind
of did this with his hand
who's I no one can see me but it's fine
yeah yeah okay yeah he's like ah take it
f5 look at me I don't know
f3 it's it the problem with playing
moves I got five is that now for example
he didn't have any weaknesses it's the
one advantage of the opening of the hip
hop now he has a weakness on e6
yesterday care however if JJ is playing
f3 which is very lame JJ shame on you it
makes it so that it doesn't look like
he's doing anything great so I don't
know
you put those like they're talking I
don't know what they're saying but it
looks they look very amused I'm getting
scared as they should be
they're poised saying more interesting
things than I am to say
I have to say I'm not super impressed by
in JJ's opening play that matter nature
is quite lame apt or something like f5
like if you're gonna play night h2 you
have to break apart the position like
you can't let them play out five and
just leave your knight there yeah you
heard Alex say let's go and slam down b5
there well I have to say b5 looks like a
pretty decent move to me this looks very
dangerous for white I would say that
blacks already better significantly
maybe ok one check now the e4 pawn is
weak he can probably grab it and
basically Black has a free attack you
can play Queen a a 2 a 2 looks really
nasty there are so many things you can
do he just plays Knight b6 he doesn't
even want the pawn and honestly like the
way JJ played this cuz now you notice
how he played a for the general rule in
the hippo is that you want to play on
you want to keep control over one side
and play on the other well JJ did he
tried to play on both sides and when you
try to play on both sides you regret it
notice if his palm weren't on a for
black wouldn't have this attack okay so
JJ trying to castle with the pawn and a
Ford just was a really poor idea so now
he's sacrificing in desperation taking
on g5 as a desperate move but at the
same time he probably hates his position
and you could tell the apothem doesn't
believe it he's like whatever JJ
whatever you say it was kind of the way
JJ reacted when they told him he was
gonna arm wrestle he's like whatever man
well it was a little bit strongly-worded
than that he said he didn't want to do I
learned some interesting things about
the organisation of this here match a
pontiff I asked him about the arm
wrestling and he says I don't know how I
feel I feel fine we arm wrestled six
years ago sorry to interrupt your back
Scott I've just played a really cool
idea what was that he plays 95 so if
Queen takes d8 he doesn't recapture he
plays Bishop h6 check and that king has
nowhere to go you have to play rook t2
ugly ugly move and then you can
recapture the Queen I don't think it was
necessary to do this I think he could
have played 96 and had accomplished a
similar thing but 95 is kind of a cool
idea
so he does force JJ to bring his queen
back again I think it was unnecessary to
put the knight on d5 but it's a cool
idea that you efficient h6 check is an
intermezzo
you got a direct your attention to the
clock here for a while
JJ's down to just 2 seconds left yeah I
think he's gonna be toast this game
toast
yeah takes and theta4 looks pretty good
I can't imagine JJ surviving this keep
in mind he's down to piece for this it's
not like he's he's up material right but
takes a metaphor it's hard to argue with
in my view and is that what he's gonna
do he's rapping on the table oh he goes
back to f6 retreat whatever alright so
h6 yes he now he's a lion Connor play
like why Queen g5 check oh he's giving
up his bishop oh my goodness look at
this taking the Queen taking the rook
illegal promotion
wow you promoted legally that's like the
face no one promotes legally especially
GM's
well they know my comers there so that's
true you got to keep it legal now it's
kind of weird like I still really like
black but now it's some kind of weird
peace and balance where he has the rook
and Knight for a queen so I don't know
any he has a pawn for it as well so
technically he's not even down anymore
and I'd say blacks king is a little open
so I can't say I'm a fan of what you
punko did I like metaphor keep a good
position stay up a piece not allow h6
but no one likes my moose yeah Knight f3
so now the problem is that if you try to
take this there's the flag it's over to
blackness to start oh my goodness see he
just showed me well we now that we're
midway through the match yeah we've had
tied one to one yeah there's a few
things we gotta clear up first of all
let's put a fork in it there's not gonna
be any arm wrestling playoff I'm very
sorry
that's the worst thing to put a fork in
right there ok now you can all leave
right know if in the event I didn't
believe the last word what I have gotten
the players and the organizer Tony Chen
and director Mike comer have have come
to the agreement that a if it's 2 to 2
then the match is tied you know it's a
friendly but it's a friendly that I
feel like these guys are they're playing
like sillier but they're still they
don't want to lose something like this I
mean I don't know this game I thought
they wanted to lose was was my
impression in this game however well hey
I think we have the the game in here yet
yeah yeah we can't even look at it yeah
so like where I was so the opening so
this is kind of where I don't like this
idea I don't like this maybe something
went wrong oh well oh the score is okay
the score is okay yeah so this kind of
position I would say like I don't like
to play h5 too early I would rather
first of all playing on both sides of
the board is a little bit of a no-no but
honestly like I would try to improve my
pieces first so for example I think this
Bishop belongs here you can maneuver the
knight place III that's kind of a nice
setup usually again even putting the
bishop on c4 is fine
but basically like these pieces don't
really belong so I kind of like playing
slow and basically taking advantage of
the fact that black can't really do that
much but playing this way is maybe
doable but yeah against something like
f5 I think you have to be more ambitious
here because if you just play f3 you
have a terrible net and h2 and black
kind of has what they want
so I was thinking even moves like Bishop
c4 trying to target this pawn even
capturing this pawn is not terrible you
can think about moves like d5 with the
idea that you're trying to undermine and
again take advantage of this weak e6
pawn and if black plays a move like a 5
now when you take your kind of happy
because you have this nice square for
the knight on g4 your can try to take
over the light squares Josh I just got
word that we have Alex a path off ready
for his interview after his victory in
game 2 well let's see what he has to say
that was definitely an in chess intense
chess game of the ages right there so
what were you thinking so so he
sacrifices on the G file right and then
you come up with this amazing knight
move well yeah I mean he was gonna go
for the checkmate with h6 and Queen
takes you seven and then Wed then he's
got to retreat his Queen all the way to
d2 and then and then you're thinking and
what was going through your mind I mean
was it I felt like I was better but I
thought 95 was not nice
sorry maybe the nicest expose better
because I would preserve my piece by the
play tonight if I have to give him a
choice to take on d8 or go back because
by taking DF he can win my piece right
take on da we take Mike win I take the
coin back in d5 but then I had Bishop h6
idea and I'm pinning him on the h-60 one
day Oh gotcha gotcha gotcha so that was
that was a great game you got the big
check in there on a1 and then you had
ideas of checkmating him or checking on
well I yes could bring my knight to be
formed into a2 as well yeah when the win
the knight win the game after losing the
first game sure well it's all tied up
1-1 we're going into halftime and uh
we'll see what happens in Game three all
right well there is evening the score
Grandmaster Alex teapot off we're gonna
take a short break here in just a moment
before we do that what are your thoughts
so far on this game is our on these
games is unexpected is it better or
worse than you thought I'm not really I
mean he Popov likes to play
provocatively he likes to play this kind
of chess and sometimes it goes well like
in the second game sometimes it goes
poorly like in the first game so you can
kind of see but but I felt like the
first game was fairly close even though
he lost an exchange he clearly got a lot
of compensation for that exchange I
should say sacked it but he got
outplayed an end game JJ got his king up
and then played very well in my opinion
the second game I think JJ played below
his standard like he kind of got thrown
by the hipbone
so this will only encourage you popped
up to play more aggressively because he
clearly got thrown by the opening any
part of got such a beautiful position
like after a Castle queenside in
particular which in my mind was a little
strange and then b5 already he took over
so I think that he popped up will only
play more aggressive from now on and JJ
will have to respond will he play like
he did in the first game or like the
second game well we will have to wait
and see what happens here like I said we
are going on a very short break we will
be back shortly
don't go too far beyond that
refrigerator because we've got some more
intense chest coming up in just a few
minutes okay thanks guys okay
citing Dave chess now take a look I have
something really interesting I want to
show you
he's pretty innocuous right but actually
White's threatening to play e5 it's ok
blacks no slouch he sees the threat and
counters it by playing he fight himself
yet white is relentless attacking e5
with the knight black defends with his
knight
in stronger games but in this game d6
was played to which the amazing response
d4 was played how can black even want to
continue here maybe Bishop g4 but black
says no no or White's s Intel for no ah
white says that's a dumb idea Bishop g4
is so stupid and I will show you the
line but I know all our viewers at home
can see it calculate it easily without
me having to move the pieces that after
de Queen da King D 895 wins the pawn
black sea's this refuses to fall for
whites tricks
and white says I'm gonna check meet you
buddy
black says no I like to develop and stop
checkmates why it says I'm gonna
redouble the attack on f7 with Queen b3
looks like Blackston quite a pickle here
wouldn't you say
Queen g7 won't do it so he plays Queen
e7 threatening to play Queen b4 check if
BB 7 comes on the board trading off the
Queen's and taking this team out of
whites attack
white of course just plays normal chess
starts developing black plays c6 to keep
that night off a d5 and b5
the golden rules are being followed
folks this is exciting stuff this is
exciting stuff which side will like
castle on nobody knows
black thinks that Bishop is really
annoying so he tries to get rid of it
but does white have a surprise for him
as Jonathan sharks like to say I'll take
those pawns and get a winning
unstoppable attack what do you have to
say about that black pieces not King d8
because castles long leads into a quick
forced win for white and the rest just
explains itself doesn't it folks I'm
attacking Europe in peace you have to
defend it in my position so strong and
so few of your pieces are in play that I
can just sacrifice all my stuff just
throw it away and check meet you but
what if you try and trade off my
strongest attacking piece will I fall
for it and take here no sir no I will
not
you
you guys in the studio Thank You Dennis
LaRue as always welcome back to the show
Ben Simon here with Grandmaster Josh
free del we are midway through the
intense chess match of the year of the
year it's the only one
GM showdown hot dog versus a Lima
rendezvous and we're about to start game
number three so I understand that we are
ready to go back to our battleground
with our chief warlord Mike comer it's a
good name from all right
Game three it's all tied up 1-1 you may
begin a pot off has the white pieces
here and clock's ticking but then again
it's not 10 second delay one minute with
a 10 second delay if you're just joining
us what a great time to join us we
basically have a what's turn into a
best-of to match up here Josh what do
you make of the opening so far so it
seems like JJ is gonna counter he popped
off by playing kind of slightly offbeat
stuff himself and it looked like they
were they were talking some smack and
then he slammed down one d4 as if it was
a novelty and here's h4 I think every
game they've designated they have to
play h4 really early is this some kind
of that this is not any theory of any
sort right Josh no okay
I mean well g6 Bishop g7 East six is not
normal Theory either but h4 in a
position like this is not ridiculous but
basically I think JJ is gonna play the
hit ball because he realized how strong
it was in the last game when he was
busted out of the opening so he's like
why don't I plant myself and maybe the
strategies genius because he's gonna see
how to refute it from me Pato d5 though
is not very hippo ish I would say why do
they call it the hippo
hmmm I don't know it's like shaped like
this weird thing see I keep doing stuff
with my hands then I realize you guys
are looking at the board so my apologies
but it's better off you don't see it
anyway so yeah Knight f3 he's just gonna
play e3 next now you have to be careful
cuz because you play d5 rather than d6
that Bishop on f4 is much stronger
placed oh my goodness JJ is taking on c4
what a lunatic not know Mona but still
like it you popped off plays he could
play e4 III and take
pawn I would say that blacks opening is
dubious at best cuz keep in mind he
can't castle so easily because that age
six pawn is gonna hang them and you do
not want to lose the age six pawn with
h5 coming so I have no idea what JJ is
thinking I think that he's gonna have
some problems I think maybe he'll try a
knight c6 but then you have to worry
about Nate b5 all the time so yeah he's
trying to play a six first which makes
sense but now he can simply take on d5
and at least personally I would not be
too envious of his position so yeah I
mean this looks very nice for white not
completely over or anything like this
but definitely pot though is very happy
with his opening and you can tell by the
confidence which was he's moving
although he always moves like that
so maybe not yeah so I don't know I
would go back to b3 looks fine but he
can really do whatever he wants
II - yeah the reason I like b3 is
because then you can think about playing
d5 in situations like this and
immediately breaking apart the pawns a
little bit whereas now with the bishop
when you - it's like a e4 I'd like to
kind of defend because there's b4 so he
just plays very simply you just + a3 to
prevent before JJ again cannot castle
which is really annoying so probably he
plays a 97 here you could think about
trying Knight f6 to try to put pressure
on the pawn again if you can force him
to play e5 or some unpleasant move it
could be nice but really he has to find
a way to get castled sometimes in the
hippo you have to be playing extremely
embarrassing King f8 to g8 h6 sticky
castle which okay they broke underneath
it yeah which needless to say at least
I'd be embarrassed to play this way but
that's the way they roll you know I am
NOT amongst hippo players I am on more
classes I'm a classicist myself even
when I play bullet so even in bullet I
won't play these a classicist yes
classical player uh-huh okay what I'm
not playing like a lunatic
but anyway so yeah here now he has to be
careful like I don't know if takes e5
and Queen e3 or takes e5 and takes d8
like it all looks a little suspicious
for black but at the same time I
definitely kind of yeah Queen e3 and now
you have to deal with this night being
attacked as well as the Queen so Queen
b6 looks nice but then your Knights a
little bit pinned up and moves like
t6 look at knowing Bishop Bishop d6 yeah
Queen c8 is a little bit awkward I would
say and once again Bishop d6 look super
annoying to me because you attacked the
night and you hit the net on e7 and keep
in mind with all those pieces attacked
you're not gonna get canceled so I think
you pop those looking for that knockout
all right please Bishop e5 I didn't like
that one as much but it's also
definitely very possible keep in mind
also you can sack on b5 occasionally and
try to go at that King on e8 yeah there
should be 5 he allowed him to castle oh
did he trick him I don't know if you
tricked him though because of Bishop d6
maybe he takes on c3 or something but
yeah I mean I don't know maybe he
tricked him but at the same time there
should be 5 was a little bit strange
there laughing so it could be he just
missed it right that's probably the case
yeah he's like putting his hands up like
huh didn't think of that oh yeah this is
quite nasty cuz now both Knights are
attacked taking on c3 is possible but
after B takes yeah he thought that
doesn't believe this for one second
but the thing now is if Knight takes e4
Knight f5 might be annoying so now he
has to consider do I take the net on e7
because then Knight takes c3 black at
least gets a couple pawns maybe he can
take on e7 takes c3 take f8 just take
everything just be like rah rah rah
that's what he's doing
oh no he recaptured oh how boring yeah
so JJ gets a couple pounds at least for
his piece usually two pawns for a piece
is not enough I would say like if he has
to play King f1 it's slightly annoying
but the nice thing he has going for him
is if he needs to get the rook into the
play h3 he can I would have maybe just
taken on c3 I don't think King f1 makes
any sense like cuz now if takes d4 F
takes I guess then he is king of two
it's always well what would you I'm
sorry what would you a play instead of
Pina core maybe just take the Queen and
play king f1 and then you can play rook
h3 and move your knight and get into
this way looked a little bit more
natural but arrow
so yeah JJ is going for the endgame
almost certainly two pawns not enough
for a piece but at the same time when
you're playing blitz chess or whatever
this random amalgamation that then my
comer decided to put together well by
the rulebook it would be rapid it would
be rapid I don't play a little bit more
like rapid but it's pretty fast for
rapid I would say that it definitely has
a lot of blitz qualities yeah I mean I
think that a pontiff should have pretty
good winning chances here I mean the
piece the pieces a lot but at the same
time JJ is trying to create counter play
he's got the rook on the second before
you have to watch out for now I'm
exactly sure what I would do here is
white rook do you two looks kind of nice
but then the problem is you have to
worry about takes and rook b8 and
skewers and pins and forks and knives
and spoons it's just not good so yeah so
he plays 91 which is not a pretty move
but he wants to kind of shoe the rook
away and now a part of learning
leaning forward more than any other time
in this match
yeah which is unfortunate because then
we can't see by what's he doing but okay
91 so I'm assuming rook a twos coming so
he can still keep the threat of b4
because if he gets the beat pawn to
create counter play it could be nice he
takes on e2 and then plays b4 check so
he's going for some kind of sacrifice to
get the b-pawn rolling but he's down a
whole rook now and a whole rook
needless to say Bensimon is a lot but
yeah d3 I don't know it seems like this
shouldn't work like for example
something like Knight f3 and Bishop e5
he chooses Knight d3 which also is
logical
I would have preferred after you though
so this kind of rook e8 crap wouldn't
annoy me and keep in mind these guys do
not have that much time at this point so
they don't have a lot of time to think
things through I would really like that
f3 Bishop e5 that looked kind of
annoying to me trade off one of the
bishops then the compensation is pretty
limited cuz he just has a B pawn for
this rook basically the extra pawn on
the Kings side is fairly irrelevant but
what is relevant is it's five seconds
too soon so these guys got a move so
yeah he trades a pair of rook so now he
just has the two bishops and that be
pawn so he needs that B pawn to make
Queen however it is a rook so yeah he's
gonna just sack for that pawn probably
but then it's only if he sucks for the
pawn then he um he could have paid
Knight c3 to be one that would have
actually ended it maybe oh wait no he
couldn't have the bishop controls that
square my bad yeah so now it's now it's
in exchange for a pawn so now it's at
least a little bit messy I would say but
uh yeah I don't know I would say that
black has pretty decent drawing chances
now and again it's one of those things
where like in a slow game it might have
been easy to win this but when you don't
have any time it's so hard to play so
yeah it's pretty tricky again I would
say he should try to trade the bishop so
an idea like Bishop c5 to d4 I really
like I think if you exchange a pair of
bishops it's going to be a little bit
easier for you to try to win because
when the bishops control so many squares
is just super annoying so yeah maybe
maybe Bishop c5 now or check on it f8
first take advantage of the fact that
King has to go to HSN but he also
doesn't have to rush I think that these
ideas will always be there yeah and look
at the the clock has been on five versus
seven seconds for a long time now
because they have that big delay I would
say positions like this you should never
think that much on one move because
really that there are no moves that are
going oh it's ticking three all to CJ he
trades on his own volition which to me
is a little bit strange but at the same
time you can't avoid it some projects
doesn't matter but yeah this looks this
looks pretty tough to hold I would say
probably the rook goes to c5 at some
point I would have put the rope to c5
first probably but it may not matter too
much you can even play rook c5 here
it's very playable but I don't know h5
is kind of nice like you it's it's
double-edged a little cuz you have to
worry about your g4 pump but the h6 pawn
is also a little bit weak but the main
problem black house here is that bishop
has to say glued today pawn because if
you allow white to get a past a pawn
you're going to lose that pawn is gonna
just win
so it means that the bishops glued to b3
while the rook can roam around the board
and now he pins back the king to g7 and
the question only is whether he can make
progress enough to win
so yes the watch out for sacrifices on
the bishop - by the way so for example
of rook b8 you're threatening to take
the bishop play King D 3 and you have a
past a pawn so I would guess that this
should be winning so I think he maybe
hasn't seen it yet you know again when
they have no time it's hard but I would
say he should he should be aiming to
sack for that Bishop and play king b3 I
think that's gonna end the game because
the bishop can't hold the apartment
right he's playing first looks long
instead which is also not terrible but I
think it's much easier just yeah so
attack the bishop and then rook before
just threatened to sack for it so what
he's doing and now he doesn't even want
it okay he brings the King in good
enough also I'm sure but he could have
he could have ended the game right now I
don't know i didn't suck on b3 yeah
that's a really good point Josh so he
just yeah it's outside a pawn is just
way too strong right but again like
these guys have no time like we take it
for granted that it's hard to see the
whole board and get a sense for all that
so he's probably like that sometimes
what can happen is you get stuck on one
idea so he's gonna go over and take the
a pawn so it's not gonna matter but
sometimes you get stuck on one idea and
that can kind of ruin your position so I
think JJ should at least try a5 it's on
points list there's no way he's like a
player of apothem strength is gonna miss
this forever right so he's gonna try
taking on a four now yeah there we go
and this should be fairly simple one
because there's just you you don't have
time to play for f6 right the pawns too
fast right like you can just take this
and you have an outside pass pawn so you
can bring your King in you can just push
you're a pawn you pushing a pawn
simplest so he's gonna okay yeah King
comes back and this should be over there
it is Alex a pontiff takes the lead
two to one getting rid of JJ's match
winning chances so the best that JJ can
do now is actually just
we have a drunk but because he didn't
want to arm-wrestle that he's just loses
the match the match is over unite
everyone
well he was he was very professional
with how he put it I mean earlier he
said this is chess okay this is this is
a mental game I don't think it's right
that we put a physical aspect into it
okay that sounds way too serious for a
time control like this like how do you
feel about this exhibition match and
they're all like oh it's fun fun is the
most important thing yet you know we're
negotiating here like everything's on
the line and there's something there's
something inside them that probably
thinks everything is on the line you
know I I hope right right I guess so
Kyle nice was asking what's on the line
yeah Kyle it's pride right it's a lot to
be on the line Thanks all right let's go
once again to Mike comer who has the
winner
Grand Master Alexei Pato all right I'm
here with the winner of Game three
Alexandre epitaphs so what were your
thoughts on the game I mean with a base
time of one minute do you ever think it
could last that long yeah I did I didn't
expect I'm in the game to be that long
it was a long one and a lot of moves too
hung the Crisco moves but but you got
the win what what what do you think that
your big turning point was maybe my
opponent played Bishop f6 breakthrough
plan but once he traded dark-squared
bishop I mean it became easier to put
pressure on his position maybe it's
still a job but I mean he traded one of
his active pieces I think that was a
mistake all right
so going into our game for you've
overcome that your old one deficit to
take a 2-1 deficit you like your chances
in a the last one well I'll be black in
the last games so I mean I'm sure my
opponent will do put all his anger in
the last game so I will have to defend
very well I mean all right yeah if not
it goes the tie breakers who knows what
that's gonna be back to the studio
they give me an official word I say it
and now Mike comer stirring the pot
again talking about a potential
tiebreaker that's all what no who knows
what's gonna go on over there but right
now officially if it's two to two we're
gonna call the match your tie I don't
know if they're good they want to have a
footrace I can have a footrace then
we'll play checkers that's fine I don't
think we should call it because I think
that it can change in a moment's notice
it really but considering these guys
have to actually agree on the timing
it'll probably be the tiebreaker be in
like two years
they'll decide on a tie-break format and
we'll come back here we'll be right back
here and tell you how it works I'm sure
that's how it's gonna it's gonna go down
you know I asked Alex earlier today what
do you what do you make of this this
match here with this crazy time control
and he said well you know this time
control it favors JJ I think if anything
if we were competing in a classical
matchup people might favor me more but
with this shorter time control it's the
chaos basically I'm paraphrasing here
the chaos is is allowing JJ to be on a
more level playing field and we might
see that we might see JJ come back who
knows I think it's quite possible I mean
again it's one game and it's as you can
see the games can go back and forth
pretty wildly so the fact and Jay
Daggett's wait I don't know how much
color even matters but I would say that
you know especially if you Pato is
committed to playing hippo again we can
see here another decisive resolve quite
easily
will we see a decisive result when we
see the hippo well let's find out it's
game number four let's go to the
battlefield with Mike Hummer all right
welcome to game number four I patatas up
two to one and you may begin and we're
off to the races JJ finishing up this
campaign as white I like how every first
move oh my goodness
this is a good way to try to draw a six
g5 this is this is trying to play for a
draw don't try this at home folks
so yeah this pawn on g5 is sorely kind
of like a sore thumb you just always got
a nurse it the rest of the game you have
to worry about h4 ideas you have to
worry about f4 ideas it's not even
putting it 9 + f6 he's just like
whatever so he resigned already game
over so he knocked over his king but as
you guys should know that is not
resignation immediately so yeah I would
say that JJ is probably gonna just do a
nice solid setup put his 92
maybe Nigeria h5 could be annoying here
so he's preventing it actually by
attacking the d4 pawn so I don't know
what JJ's gonna try to choose here again
I think simply castling is perfectly
fine
g3 trying to play with h4 f4 also looks
quite reasonable again it's one of those
things where he's black setup lost or
anything like that not necessarily but I
would say that he's King and his
position can come under threat much more
easily so JJ's castling queenside he's
committed to playing with h4 so he
popped off is understandably trying to
stir up stir the pot on the Queen side
so yeah he gets in b5 before but I'm not
so sure this does that much I might have
chosen a four as a square because I
think it's likely blacks gonna want to
move that deep on and now you can run
the pawns up the board so I don't know
if I would have chosen to be one but
again may not matter too much so JJ is
advancing his pawns on the Queen side he
gets an f5 I don't know if f5 would have
been my choice I kind of like targeting
the Jeep on which is kind of weak but
it's probably also it's not so bad
Knight to d5 so I'm kind of curious how
pins work like either Bishop e4 Bishop
e5 it seems like blacks gonna hold on
either way I also like the idea of
playing Knight g3 and trying to put that
net on h5 then a turn h5 looks like a
real pest that's a deal to try to deal
with
sure enough that's what he's trying to
do bishop e49 g3 and the problem is that
it black for black the castle was really
kind of annoying and if you don't castle
you're still gonna be under threat so i
don't know i think JJ should have a
pretty good position but as we've seen
it's never that easy the main problem is
it just takes too many moves for black
to create Queen side threats even with
your pawns as far as up there as they
are Knight h5 is coming awfully fast
so a pot top takes this bishop and plays
d5 so he's changing the nature of the
position a little bit but I would say
that he's not really solving the net h5
problems so even if JJ simply retreats
I'm not exactly sure that he has not
much counter play ah he plays in that h5
first so JJ trying to play super
aggressive the idea being that if you
try to castling now we're defending the
Bishop f6 you have to worry about which
is quite nasty so this is a really nice
idea by JJ and I believe a pop ups idea
was to at least play take the bishop so
at least h4 carries less sting so yeah
he's gonna have to trade these pieces
now but after Knight takes g7 checking
back Knight back to h5 it looks at the
very least kind of unpleasant but maybe
he'll get some kind of play here I'm not
exactly sure because the thing is like
with the 9 inch 5 it takes at least a
few moves so black can get some kind of
Queen side play going he could have some
chances because even though eventually
you will lose on the Kings side it may
take a few moves Bishop e7 and JJ plays
d5 so JJ wants Queen d4 and putting
pressure on blacks Queen side this is a
really nice idea I think he popped up
may have actually considered playing
Knight d5 giving up the e pawn just to
parentheses I'm sure he missed it
so now Knight takes d5 Queen d4 I'm
assuming is coming and again maybe maybe
he can kind of survive for a few moves
by playing rook g8 or rook h7 but it's
ugly survival but there are some tricks
for example if Queen d4 rook moves 92
with the idea of Knight takes e4 it
looks great then you have to contend
with Knight f4 the idea being that if
the Queen's if you try you have time to
trade the Queen's will check but you
have to watch out for an ad to meet in
the air
and it looks like I played f6 so c5 what
on earth is happening then we just gave
him a free pot is that right
Queen e7 night 64 I mean he's giving
away his house is what he's doing
no this was not expected I thought he
would try some Knight f4 idea but I
think he wasn't able to do it I guess
there was Queen c5 check as well so 25
check queen e7 but I don't know why he
played up 6 it seemed like that gave JJ
extra time and he already had a lot of
time but it could be that the Apostles
position was just bad this I think is
lost because 95 check is coming next
except 6 check is coming if you move the
King 96 in soul positions just falling
apart this is a very strange choice and
it must draw again Alex was he careless
here
I think it's positioned the fact is when
you play like this sometimes your
position is just so hard to hang on to
that even if you're not careless yeah
that's over give it Wow ok so the match
is tied two to two let's say well I was
wondering what the players are saying at
the board like hey it happened of course
we have a two two to tie yeah what now
I'm awaiting will be awaiting my comers
word and maybe he'll be talking with the
players here who knows already
yeah the official decision I've been
there's not gonna be any arm wrestling
it just won't be it just won't be Josh
yeah
that's pretty severe that's oh I didn't
know you were so adamant about it our
danny Machuca in my ear telling me that
i don't even want to believe it Danny I
don't want to believe it oh my goodness
a coin flip tie break come what does
that even mean come on let's it they're
gonna flip a coin what is this you know
there's a reason why the 2018 Sinfield
Cup was called a three-way tie
okay of all the players don't the coin
flip is basically our only option out of
this let's just call it a tie right
no I'll believe it when I see it if
they're flipping a coin I want to see it
yeah the point has two sides to it yeah
let's see what's going on here but
anyway so the match was tied the from
the first ever intense chess match
called the GM showdown
are you I mean the results we were
talking about how this time control kind
of levels the playing field it's
definitely surprising and I mean it's
not surprised I would say like the you
know the the greater practical players
will do well because they're not trying
to be perfectionist they're just trying
to play kind of quickly and I would say
that it was obviously a potluck was
choosing kind of crazy lines like if
you're playing if they were playing for
serious money he's not gonna play ECG
five but at the same time it's fun to
watch and I think that the players are
not taking it seriously enough that
they're going to like be going hardcore
and a time control like this but I would
say that it was obvious that JJ was
playing a little more normally and in
pot that was playing out there but as we
saw they tied the match right so you
know well let's see what JJ has to say
he's sitting standing by with Mike comer
I'm back with the winner of Game four JJ
a lemur on D so that was a pretty big
knockout you head there and and you foul
my advice you knew it never play off six
and I put off solenoid and you took
advantage did you know you had the win
when he played that yeah of course I
mean if you're playing the black pieces
and you play off six clearly there is
something wrong in your position and you
should try to avoid it at all costs and
I took care of the Vice and also yeah
and you didn't play f6 as the white
pieces either play with white f6 that
means you already advanced a little too
much so it might be a good move today we
were discussing if f6 is possible with
white it might be good yeah cool so you
wanted as the tiebreak to arm-wrestle
for the victory so are you a experienced
arm wrestler so that would have been a
first for iPad office well I guess
instead we're gonna have a very
unconventional tie break a coin flip
well stay tuned
get your wagers in who's got heads who's
got tails we'll see when we come back
that's terrible Josh Josh what's going
on I I would say though it is fitting
the time control given they have to play
at this time until it feels like a coin
flip anyway so might as well just flip
one but I still hate this idea
is a terrible horrible ever thought of
this shame one this is horrible horrible
I want to take this opportunity I'm
gonna file a protest I need a protest
number where where do I file a protest
well I think I have your individuals
because right now we want to thank our
very special match organizers Tony Chen
and Danny Machuca thank you for all so
those are the guys that came up with the
coin I'm thanking them I'm thanking them
Josh okay come on now
all right all right if you have any
questions in the chat hit us up we are
checking it
shout out to Kyle nice and chat
appreciate you watching probably right
here at the Chess Club also these
players their their men about town they
are on the internet suits all the time
before before I play go to cocktail
parties you can't miss them before I put
their social media over we're ready for
this playoff let's go to the point
[Laughter]
alright we are live with the official
coin flip I Pat of has the heads JJ has
the tails this is a real-life quarter
all right are we ready and the winner is
the devastation Oh so congratulations to
the winner
JJ he'll be getting interviewed back in
the studio momentarily well-earned Josh
there are times in chess and in sport
when you witness a great match and then
there's an amazing climax and at the end
of that you say these two sportsmen
really gave it hell they gave it their
all and this was not one of those times
I don't I disagree with you Ben I think
that they kind of held their held it
together during that coin toss they
didn't falter they waited for Mike to
call the coin it looked like my flip
that around I wasn't even sure he knew
what he was doing and he still was able
to call the coin toss and they were able
to just sit there let the coin toss be
decided well and that takes guts we know
now that grandmaster JJ Ali Miranti is
the champion of GM showdown after that
unique playoff and Danny did I hear
right we're gonna have him in here in
Studio B is that right okay
yeah okay we'll be right back with our
champion of the match JJ Yeley Mehran
day but in the meantime Dennis take it
away
hey thanks guys this is some exciting
chess Wow
I am just a happy camper all this chess
I don't know what to do I am beside
myself anyway I want to talk to you guys
about a very interesting position take a
look at this what a doozy oh my goodness
how does white proceed here is he
winning is he losing drawing nobody
knows unless he finds the amazing move
look - whatever square that is
now the casual observer may say didn't
you just hang your book on h6 and I'll
tell him take it
and then I'll say checkmate back to you
guys in the studio
you
you
or the blues what about
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error instead boogie through the
city and discover the music that gave
the Blues their name at the National
Blues Museum Broadway Oyster Bar or even
the legendary Blueberry Hill so whether
you love the Cardinals the Blues or the
Blues come play with us you guys know I
can't play this right st. Loup is always
exploring welcome back everyone this is
we're joined by Jay Jay who won that
intense intense coin flip I hope you
guys managed to survive it didn't have
to get drunk didn't have to do anything
crazy to survive the drama of that coin
flip how does it feel to win a match it
feels good honestly it's the first time
I think not the first time but luck is
deciding my games even someone else
deciding it for me and I think that was
also interesting but yeah I mean the the
format's actually intense when when you
go like start when the clock starts
ticking yeah it gets very annoying but
other than that I think it's very
interesting it was my official first
time playing although we did train today
first time playing this time controls oh
yeah yeah but like the time control to
me seemed very strange
I was wondering kind of what you thought
was it a fun time control did you think
it was stressful like what was nice if
it's like if you played the game
correctly and if you actually pick the
right moves in the first 10 seconds you
can actually play like 20 30 minutes
long games it felt like but on I mean
our chest was nowhere near perfect
because we were more like playing here
in there a little bit more entertaining
and wrestling around yeah yeah but well
we definitely noticed that he played the
hippo he really played very aggressively
and it seemed like in the second game
worked out well for him and in the third
game he played more or less normally and
that worked out well
but in the first and last games it
seemed like it worked more in your favor
piggy late in the last game where he
just got all dead position right away
yeah and the last one he played the
second move g5 I think that was a little
bumpy rated hippo but I understand he
wants to
and he wanted to just get me out of book
rather than play something I think you
mean you didn't have g5 prepared a bit
surprised I know he likes to play g5
whenever he can that's why I played d4 I
stopped them from g5 but wow he just
wanted to play it it anyway
should've played h4 after he 6 yeah you
could have made him play something
really silly did you have a particularly
favor move move in the games or a
favorite moment where you thought you've
made a nice decision do you have any
moments where you thought that they were
just really interesting like well yeah
the first game I think is basically when
we both couldn't get adjusted to the
time control + the positions and nothing
I we tried to play a little bit more
like a normal yeah and also entertaining
like trying to do a little bit of
everything but then I realized the 16
sacrifice is actually very good yeah for
him and felt very uncomfortable when you
have an exchange would like the open
files but my rooks were like behind my
yeah when I when I first saw it I
thought that this exchange shock was at
least safe for him it's not like he was
doing fine but I thought that this was a
key moment like after you took on f6 he
had a moment he could have so you can
see it there on the board I thought that
he would try efore yeah absolutely I
think he underestimated the power of the
King entering and the potential of the
sea a rook actually uh I'm actually very
curious what your plan is after you four
because it seems like it's difficult to
play a move in some ways yeah I was kind
of like also a little nervous maybe in
the time control cuz like you have ten
seconds delay but once that ten seconds
goes down and you see the clock ticking
that's very annoying I find it even in
my regular games when I see the clock
ticking I find it annoying yeah actually
you know that uh you know that there is
like less than a minute for sure yes
that's what you start with yeah it's
very nervous when the time goes then I
did not really think that deep as you
can tell about it because we're given
ten seconds yeah I mean you don't have
that much time I was saying that one of
the things about these positions is
sometimes the objective value of the
position probably doesn't matter as much
as like how quickly can you play moves
and this end game I thought was quite
tricky but I definitely thought like I
would have probably played e4 without
thinking I just I
don't want the King in oh yeah maybe
it's just but even here maybe he didn't
want to allow maybe he didn't like rook
d7 and then kind of have issues with the
bishop but even their rook d4 it feels
like he's not really risking much I mean
maybe the objective result is draw yeah
but again that's the objective result
but again we don't know how long the
games can last no one's checking the
number of moves really yeah we're just
playing casually and it can go down to
anything I think I had like 10 15
seconds here and yet like four yeah
again we have the delay but yeah I mean
my general feeling in the nen game like
this also is like it's easy for things
to go kind of go wrong and and I really
liked how you got your King into play I
thought this was really nice and then
here what was really funny is so I saw
this rook takes d4 idea but I thought he
needed to take upon for it to work
because then you just Queen your pawn
but then I realized that you don't
actually have to Queen there pocket you
just you just like the exchange and you
win because your king is so strong so I
thought this was really nice that you
kind of because you had a tough end game
to play but you organized your pieces
really well yeah and the thing is he can
never play like rook c6 after any rook
takes d4 because I promote on the C file
and he also promotes ours
yeah I mentioned that but just to show
you guys what I mean after c3 rook c6
looks like it solves the problem very
cleverly but the problem is after takes
takes c2 yeah we got the same time when
we Queen on the same file yeah I know
Queen you do Queen first right I can
even promote to a real good I feel like
yeah if he would hide the Queen so
promoting to a rook an alternative
winning variation so yeah I thought this
was good I thought game to the the
knight h2f three castles Queen side
thing was a bit much and I got you into
some trouble I missed them more b5 I
actually overestimated my position and
that can go very well down like yes what
happened like the moment he actually got
play I didn't know what to do I did have
interesting play after I sacrifice the
bishop but I don't think it was anywhere
near sufficient maybe I mean I thought
that he actually like after he sacked
the bishop I thought that he could have
played simpler like he tried to be very
fancy yeah because honestly I wanted to
take on the 8th and
Game two after he played Knight to d5 as
far as I remember yeah so here I already
thought it was really bad and I realize
after night day I thought he might play
Knights you see also anything wins
probably because like if you ever take
them right six check easy to miss in
either line so I was going to take on
the eight pretty much very quickly but
then I figured the knight on d5 is loose
so I went back yeah but I think this is
the game I actually completely lost the
control of my clock and I stacked the
Queen I actually thought the Queen sack
made sense like I thought that he should
know I thought he was actually gonna
play Knight f4 on you yeah yeah one and
then it looks really bad I missed Knight
f6 94 but honestly I had two seconds I
think at that I just didn't when you
have no time it's really hard to play
yeah I mean it looks like you have the
ten seconds delay and but it wasn't that
easier you think yeah overall so but
again like it was really fun to follow
and I thought that there were periods of
the game where you guys were definitely
you know you were playing you had no
time but you guys were actually playing
like pretty decent moves and then there
were times where you just had trouble
playing well one of you just had a
position that was too different game
three I collapsed because I had five
seconds which is a good amount of time
mm-hmm but then I played Bishop f6 a
little bit when I was a little nervous
in nervous when you should never do that
in such positions trade-off the bishop
pair oh yeah yeah that was very very
yeah the thing is though I thought he
could force the Bishop trade anyway like
really c5 to D force
okay good probably and here I missed
that if I take on any three just expect
that's also not ideal but again it still
turned out not so easy because of my be
pawn being a little dangerous but he
found this move Knight a4 takes on b2
simplifying to an endgame might not be
winning but yeah my impression was that
I was but it wasn't easy especially
after the bishops came off it's very
easy to play with white because he puts
everything on dark squares I cannot
attack anything and he can usually sack
on b3 as well and not just when that and
yeah he when is took his time but like
it's gonna be true I mean he was just
playing here and there if I hang the
bishop it will be easier for him rather
taking opponent I suppose that's true
yeah so any final thoughts on the match
or what you what you liked about it what
you didn't like
yeah intense chest is actually very
intense I I
before coming here I thought the games
can last 20-30 minutes but once you
actually start playing it's not as like
easy I mean I mean of course it's not
easy you're still playing chess at the
end of the day but the time can actually
fly away once you let that ten seconds
go then my advice for next players is
not to let that ten seconds as much as
they can so really try to hold your time
high and then keep it like play it oh
yeah nice rate and then don't let your
time good to them I try not to blend
thereof obviously but it's just mixing
oh it is alright well congratulations on
your coin flip women it was a lot of fun
to watch yeah it was pretty cool alright
alright so we're gonna switch to a
commercial break but don't go away hey
thanks guys things are getting really
intense up there I'm here to help offer
some insight just into chess in general
now many new to chess or even
experienced club players are of the
opinion that white is slightly better in
the starting position stock fish and
many other engines give us an evaluation
of white being up 0.2 it's roughly the
value of a quarter of one of these guys
to them all I have to say is take a look
at this line
where's your advantage net white back to
you guys in the studio
all right well that'll do it oh there it
is
hey how's it going to your piece well
we've had one heck of a day this has
certainly been an experience here with
intense chess and the GM showdown
it's been fun has your opinion of the
time control change since we started I
know you were like what is this when we
started but you know you're the biggest
fan of intense chess right no I thought
that the games are entertaining the
players were fun that it's just
important and it definitely had its
moments I would not want to play this
time control I think that it's it seems
like it's a very awkward time control to
play when you're used to other kind of
things but at the same time I like that
we're throwing different things out
there seeing how players who are this
strong adapt to it is kind of
interesting
I'm not a fan of the time control but I
can't say I didn't enjoy the match yeah
it was a fun match I would prefer to
have called it a time myself that's not
the way that it crumbled jg ali miranda
is ali marathi is the champion well you
know 2019 has been one heck of a year
here at the st. Louis chess club and
we're wrapping it up for this big year
the last one of the decade the last full
decade that the Chess Club has been in
business and we've had the first full
decade that I said last the first I
don't know what I said anyway the first
full decade has just been a decade guys
it has it's been over 11 years now and
2019 was the busiest year 2020 is gonna
be more workable you know the grand
chest tour has just been announced we
have the five different legs on the tour
they're announced and actually the first
big broadcast of 2020 has just been
announced for the st. Louis chess club
it's the Karen's Cup Kansas second
annual Karen's Cup and it will begin on
Friday February the 7th 10 of the best
women players in the world will be right
here in st. Louis for a nine-day round
robin and the the dream team will be
here in studio a we may have alternate
language for you in Studio B but
regardless it's gonna be a really fun
time oh for sure I worked as a
journalist for that event last year and
the games like and I naturally followed
the games as I was doing online stuff
working the Twitter account stuff like
that and they were fun like though their
games were so fun in that tournament and
the players it's a pretty big paws fun
the players are super into it you get
really interesting stuff so I would
definitely recommend tuning in to that
one executive director of the Chess Club
Toni rich and Friends are finalizing the
roster and that will be made available
to everybody next month so stick around
to us chess champs calm our YouTube
channel of course and on Facebook
st. Louis chess club I think that'll do
it here for us in this session and for
us in 2019 so let's give us some
shoutouts what do you say Josh world's
greatest production B team presenting
this event we have co-promoter an
organizer technical director Danny
Machuca in the control room along with
Isaac Krantz on graphics and audio I
have to give Tony Chen a big shout out
for Manning the cameras and and some mic
work and just anything we needed done he
did thank you Tony and Mike comer of
course we couldn't do it without the
world's greatest tournament director we
for sure couldn't do without my comer
and I have to say the guys behind the
scenes making a sound making us sound
good making sure we come in well and at
least in my case that is not an easy
task so I have to hand it to them they
did a great job and of course without my
comer why were you even having this
event seriously so you may also notice
that the players were not playing on a
dgt board that not not those digital
boards that relay the moves
automatically they were playing or not
playing on a regular a nice wooden table
that's because we had Nick risco here at
the Chess Club relaying the moves to us
so we could look at them on LY chess org
so did I hit everybody I think I did
okay well that'll do it so all the
players of course the players for
agreeing
I'm 90% certain they agreed to be here
today it's unclear they definitely
didn't agree to an arm-wrestling
competition they agreed to come here and
play a few games and considering the
on vacation right now that was a pretty
nice right yeah it froze gotta hand it
to both JJ and Alex that was pretty cool
too they came down and uh good hopes to
them for the Pan Am's coming up this one
26 representing flew in Charlotte chess
Center so I'm sure they'll be giving it
their all for that event so this has
been a production like I said of the
world's greatest production B team
he's Grandmaster Josh freed L my name is
Ben Simon until 2020 or you know maybe
we'll come up with something else and do
something in New Year's I don't know we
say so long from the show-me state
you
you